john treach is standing by at raider
headquarters but first we go to victoria
saha who was in court this morning as
ruggs made his appearance victoria
new details came out in court today
giving us a better idea of just how
horrific that crash was but first we are
waiting in front of clark county
detention center waiting for rugs to be
released because we just learned that he
did post his 150 thousand dollar bill
that was ordered by the judge today
i've never seen a case
in my 41 years here in las vegas
of a person who's charged with a crime
driving in excess of 150 miles an hour
henry rugs the third faces the judge in
a wheelchair and a neck brace for the
first time since tuesday morning's
deadly crash in court the assistant
district attorney revealed ruggs was
driving 156 miles per hour just seconds
before crashing into the back of the
toyota rav4 23-year-old tina tintor was
driving his blood alcohol level was
.161
twice the legal limit two hours after
the crash the state wanted a million
dollars bail but rux's attorney wanted
to point out his client's clean past
your honor is a young man who has never
been in trouble before from what we
understand
never a traffic violation
he has consistently followed rules and
regulations
he played for a major division one
national championship football team the
victim's family was also in court this
morning
it's america and people are entitled to
lawyers what punishment do you think he
deserves outside the courthouse chesnov
dodged questions from reporters
police also found a loaded gun in rugs's
car the district attorney says that
they're waiting to see if more evidence
comes out so they can file a charge
related to that and considering rux's
girlfriend also suffered serious
injuries he could face another dui
charge he's expected back in court next
wednesday victoria saha live local now